Back in the '60s, when Stephen was a young surgeon in Boston, a guy came in with abdominal pain, which turned out to be his gallbladder. He needed an operation. But the guy told Stephen this story of how, 12 years before, he'd come into that exact same hospital and had had cancer. It started in his stomach and had spread to his belly. The doctors opened him up.
回到60年代，当斯蒂芬还是波士顿的一名年轻外科医生时，有个男人因腹痛就诊，结果发现是胆囊的问题。他需要做手术。但那人向斯蒂芬讲述了12年前他曾在同一家医院被诊断出患有癌症的经历。癌症从他的胃部开始，蔓延到了腹部。医生们为他剖开了腹部。
And the surgeons had seen cancer that had spread into his liver and throughout his abdomen. They could do nothing and they just closed the abdomen and sent him home to die. And yet, here he was 12 years later, seeming quite healthy.
外科医生们发现癌症已经扩散到他的肝脏和整个腹腔。他们对此无能为力，只好缝合伤口让他回家等死。然而，12年后，他却站在了这里，看起来相当健康。
Stephen was skeptical. Cancer usually does not just go away with no treatment at all. The guy must have gotten the story wrong in some way.
斯蒂芬对此表示怀疑。癌症通常不会在没有任何治疗的情况下自行消失。那个人一定是在叙述过程中搞错了什么。
Then I went back to the patient's chart and I read, in fact, the pathology reports. And I was still skeptical. So then I went back and actually pulled out the slides to be sure in fact he had had the cancer. And we reviewed the slides, and in fact, it was a cancer. And then I made sure it was in fact the same patient. And in fact, it was.
于是我查阅了病人的病历，看了病理报告。我依然表示怀疑。所以我回去调出了当时的切片，以确认他是否真的患过癌症。我们复查了切片，结果显示确实是癌症。然后我确认了这确实是同一位病人。事实证明，就是他。
And then when you opened him up, were you fully expecting you were going to still find some cancer?
那么当你剖开他的时候，你是否完全预料到还会发现一些癌症？
Well, it was 12 years later and I didn't know what to expect. I operated on him, took out his gallbladder, examined the inside of his abdomen, and all of the cancer that had been present 12 years earlier had completely disappeared in the absence of any treatment.
那是12年后了，我不知道会发现什么。我为他做了手术，切除了胆囊，检查了他的腹腔内部，结果发现12年前存在的那些癌症在没有任何治疗的情况下完全消失了。
It appeared that this patient's body had somehow rejected his cancer. This patient set me on a quest for the next 25 years to try to explain how such a thing could happen.
看来这位病人的身体以某种方式排斥了他的癌症。这位病人让我开始了此后25年的探索，试图解释这种事情是如何发生的。
And in fact, this doctor, Stephen Rosenberg, is now a pioneer in inventing immunotherapies based on that research at The National Cancer Institute, where he's chief of surgery. Now, it's interesting, you can find the story about this early case of his all over the place. It circulates on the internet, it shows up in books about people spontaneously recovering from cancer, and he is not happy about that. He kind of hates it, in fact. Because he says that this story gives people false hope. In his career, he's seen maybe 10,000 cancer patients, and this is the only case like this that he has ever encountered. It is just fantastically rare. And it is so easy, he says, for patients to get their hopes up. How could anybody not get their hopes up? And Dr. Rosenberg has seen lots of patients taken advantage of by people who play on this dream of a spontaneous recovery.
事实上，这位医生，斯蒂芬·罗森伯格，现在是基于该项研究发明免疫疗法的先驱，他在美国国家癌症研究所担任外科主任。有趣的是，你可以在各地找到关于他早期这个病例的故事。它在互联网上流传，出现在关于人们从癌症中自愈的书籍里，而他对此并不高兴。事实上，他有点厌恶这一点。因为他说这个故事给了人们虚假的希望。在他的职业生涯中，他见过大约10,000名癌症患者，这是他遇到的唯一一个这样的病例。这实在是太罕见了。他说，患者很容易产生希望。谁能不产生希望呢？而且罗森伯格医生看到许多病人被那些利用这种自愈梦想的人所利用。
People who prey on cancer patients, offering quack treatments, often take advantage of cancer patients who are desperate. And I've seen entire families devastated as their entire resources are devoted to treatments of no value.
那些掠夺癌症患者、提供江湖骗术的人，往往会利用走投无路的癌症患者。我见过整个家庭因为将全部资源投入到毫无价值的治疗中而变得一无所有。
Still, hope is important. So what do you do when people place hope in things that probably are not going to work? Well, lots of times his patients come to him asking about vitamins, and herbs, and visualization, and other treatments that have not been proven by science. And if the treatments aren't actually going to hurt them in any way, he says, sure, do it. Studies have shown that patients who are embracing life, feeling more hopeful, feeling more in control of their situation, do better, respond better to medical treatment of all kinds. There are real health effects to hope itself.
尽管如此，希望依然重要。那么，当人们把希望寄托在那些很可能无效的事情上时，该怎么办呢？很多时候，他的病人会来问他关于维生素、草药、意象疗法以及其他未经科学证实的方法。他说，如果这些治疗方法不会以任何方式伤害他们，那就去做吧。研究表明，拥抱生活、感到更有希望、对自己的处境感到更有掌控力的病人，病情会更好，对各种医疗手段的反应也更好。希望本身就有着真实的健康效应。
And so, today on our radio show, we have two stories of hope, the power of hope, hope in some things that are not very likely, I have to say. We have stories about the great side of that and the maybe less great side of that. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
所以，今天我们的广播节目里有两个关于希望的故事，关于希望的力量，以及我必须说，对一些不太可能的事情抱有希望。我们有关于这一面伟大之处的故事，也有可能不那么伟大之处的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our program today in two acts. Act One, a son tries to help his mom in a faraway place defy the laws of medical science. Act Two, a daughter tries to help her dad by going to a faraway place to defy the laws of the United States of America. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为两幕。第一幕，一个儿子试图帮助他在远方的妈妈挑战医学科学定律。第二幕，一个女儿试图通过前往远方来帮助她的父亲挑战美利坚合众国的法律。请继续收听。
Act One, Changing the Channeler.
第一幕，改变通灵者。
You may remember Davy Rothbart. He's been on our show a few times. At one point, he came onto the show to tell the story of his mother, Barbara, who's a suburban mom in Ann Arbor, Michigan, who seems like lots of funny, smart moms that you have met in your life, except that she channels an ancient being named Aaron. Aaron is a Buddhist monk. Aaron gives advice along Buddhist lines to people who come into the house. He showed up in Barbara's life-- I think that's the right way to say that. He showed up in Barbara's life years ago. Barbara is also deaf. She hasn't been able to hear anything for decades. And a while back, she heard about this healer in Brazil, a man who goes by the name Joao de Deus, John of God, who, people said, could make the deaf hear. And she wanted to go down and see if he could help her out.
你可能还记得戴维·罗斯巴特。他上过我们节目几次。有一次，他来节目讲述了他母亲芭芭拉的故事，她是密歇根州安阿伯市的一位郊区妈妈，看起来和你生活中遇到的许多风趣、聪明的妈妈没什么不同，只是她会传导一个名叫亚伦的古老存在。亚伦是一位佛教僧侣。亚伦会为来家里的人提供基于佛教理念的建议。他出现在芭芭拉的生活中——我想这样说比较合适。他是几年前出现在芭芭拉生活里的。芭芭拉还是个聋子。几十年来她一直听不见任何声音。前不久，她听说巴西有一位治疗师，名叫若昂·德·德乌斯（上帝的若昂），据说他能让聋人听见声音。她想去看看他能否帮助她。
Davy is really close to her and he agreed to along.
戴维和她很亲近，他同意陪她一起去。
She was very hopeful about it. She wouldn't say, I'm going to come back, I'm going to be hearing. But I could just tell that, in the months leading up to our trip, she was getting more and more excited about it. She started just dropping little things in the conversation, like one night, me and her were talking about-- my little brother has a new album coming out.
她非常有希望。她不会说“我要回来，我会听得见”，但我能感觉到，在去旅行前的几个月里，她变得越来越兴奋。她开始在谈话中不经意地提到一些小事，比如有一天晚上，我和她聊天——我弟弟有一张新专辑要发行了。
Your brother has a band?
你弟弟有个乐队？
Yeah, he's a musician. So my mom, she'd give me a little, funny smile, and she'd just say, I can't wait to hear it. I got excited, too. I talked to her about this on tape.
是啊，他是位音乐家。所以我妈妈会给我一个顽皮的小微笑，然后说：“我等不及要听听看了。”我也变得兴奋起来。我在磁带录音中和她谈过这件事。
I want to hear Peter singing. I want to hear my mother's voice, voices of the people I love. Dad's voice, which I have heard, of course, but will not remember.
我想听彼得唱歌。我想听我母亲的声音，听我爱的人的声音。爸爸的声音，我当然听过，但已经记不住了。
Oh, stop the tape for a second, Davy. We should say, your mom is deaf, but she can talk. And she reads lips, so whenever people hear you on these tapes you're talking really slowly and distinctly so she can read your lips, and you're also signing to her a lot of times, too.
噢，戴维，暂停一下录音。我们应该说明一下，你妈妈是聋子，但她会说话。她会读唇语，所以每当人们在这些磁带里听到你说话时，你说话都非常缓慢且清晰，这样她才能读懂你的唇语，而且很多时候你还在用手语和她交流。
Right, to exaggerate the space between words.
没错，为了夸大词与词之间的间隔。
I want to hear some of my favorite music. Back at Thanksgiving, you asked me what songs I remembered, and all of my music is from the '60s. I want to hear what's happened to music in 40 years.
我想听听我最喜欢的一些音乐。感恩节的时候，你问我记得哪些歌，我所有的音乐都是60年代的。我想听听40年来音乐发生了什么变化。
Would you like to hear some 50 Cent?
你想听点50 Cent的歌吗？
Some?
一些？
50 Cent?
50 Cent？
Want to hear some 50 Cent? Do you mean two quarters clinging together?
想听点50 Cent吗？你是说两枚硬币撞击的声音吗？
No, the rapper 50 Cent.
不，说唱歌手50 Cent。
I've never heard of the rapper 50 Cent. I want to hear everything.
我从来没听说过说唱歌手50 Cent。我想听所有的东西。
Back when my mom could hear, she loved listening to music. Now she still sings sometimes.
我妈以前能听见的时候，她特别喜欢听音乐。现在她偶尔还会唱歌。
She still sings sometimes?
她现在还会唱歌？
Yeah, it kind of sounds weird. Well, it sounds interesting.
是啊，听起来有点奇怪。嗯，听起来很有意思。
Because she can't hear herself at all, right?
因为她完全听不到自己的声音，对吧？
Right, she has 0% hearing.
对，她听力完全丧失了。
A favorite song of mine that I love to hear is "Amazing Grace." Do you know that? I can't sing it on tune. [SINGING] Amazing grace, how sweet the sound, that saved a soul like me. I once was lost, but now I'm found, was blind but now I see. [END SINGING] This song, of course, far predates my deafness, but I learned it just before I lost my hearing.
我最喜欢的一首歌是《奇异恩典》。你知道这首歌吗？我唱不准调。[歌唱] 奇异恩典，何等甘甜，我罪已得赦免。前我失丧，今被寻回，瞎眼今得看见。[歌唱结束] 当然，这首歌在我失聪很久之前就有了，但我在失去听力前刚学会它。
When you can hear again, you will be able to listen to the tapes of yourself singing.
等你又能听见的时候，你就能听听你自己唱歌的录音了。
I'd say, ahhh.
我会说，啊。
So Davy, before you guys went to Brazil, what did you think was going to happen? Did you view this as, oh, my mom is going to be disappointed? Was there a part of you where you thought that she might get a miracle cure?
那么戴维，在你们去巴西之前，你认为会发生什么？你当时觉得“哦，我妈会失望的”吗？有没有那么一瞬间你觉得她可能会获得奇迹般的治愈？
You know what? I had no idea. Who knows? And I think my mom's excitement got me excited about it, too. So I had heard stories from her friend who had been down there and had seen Joao heal deaf people.
你知道吗？我完全不知道。谁知道呢？我觉得我妈的兴奋也让我跟着兴奋起来了。我听过她朋友的故事，她去过那里，亲眼见过若昂治愈聋人。
Wait, and your mom's friend actually saw this happen with her own eyes?
等等，你妈妈的朋友真的亲眼见到过这件事发生？
Yeah. So I was also nervous because sometimes it was sort of heartbreaking because I would see her begin to get so excited about it.
是的。所以我也很紧张，因为有时这让人有点心碎，我能看到她开始对此变得如此兴奋。
So Davy, where are we now?
那么戴维，我们现在在哪儿？
Now we're down in Brazil. It took us 31 hours to get there from Michigan. It's in a tiny town in the middle of Brazil called Abadiania. It's just, really, like a little village with a few farms and some houses, a little factory where they make bricks. And you know, a lot of sick people wandering around.
我们现在在巴西。从密歇根到那儿我们花了31个小时。那是在巴西中部一个叫阿巴迪亚尼亚的小镇。它真的就像一个只有几户农场和一些房子、一家制砖小厂的小村庄。而且，你知道，周围到处都是生病的人。
And this is the sort of place where the town's main industry is healing tourists?
这是一个以接待医疗游客为主要产业的小镇吗？
Yeah, it's like a one-company town, a miracle town. People have come here on buses from all over Brazil. They'll drive for 36 hours just to visit for a few hours with Joao and then go home. And everywhere you go, people are telling these miracle stories. There's this guy, Marcel, who owns a little pizza restaurant. He actually came there because his dad had been sick.
是的，这就像个一业支撑的城镇，一个奇迹之城。人们从巴西各地坐大巴来到这里。他们开车开上36个小时，只为和若昂见上几个小时，然后回家。无论你走到哪里，人们都在讲述这些奇迹故事。有个叫马塞尔的人，他经营着一家小披萨店。他之所以来这里，是因为他爸爸病了。
I have a friend, Alessandro. He lives in Abadiania, and I show you when he walk around. He had multiple sclerosis. That's the right name?
我有个朋友，亚历山德罗。他住在阿巴迪亚尼亚，我带你去看他走路的样子。他患有多发性硬化症。是这个名字吗？
Yeah, sclerosis.
是的，硬化症。
OK, he could not walk, problem to move, even to talk. Only his mother could understand him. He came here today, every day you can see he go into university, walking, he play volleyball with the people around.
好，他曾经不能走路，移动都很困难，连话都说不清楚。只有他妈妈能听懂他在说什么。他来到这里，现在你每天都能看到他去上大学，走路，他和周围的人一起打排球。
I figured, while I'm going with my mom to help her out, see if she can get her hearing back, I'd try to get healed, too. I have this skin thing, it's called psoriasis. And basically, it's like your skin gets kind of all red and scaly looking. And I have it on my chest and my back and part of my scalp.
我想，既然我陪妈妈去帮她看能不能恢复听力，我也顺便试试能不能治好我。我有一种皮肤病，叫银屑病。基本上，就是你的皮肤会变得又红又像鳞片一样。我胸部、背部和部分头皮上都有。
We should say to people who are trying to picture this that we're not talking about like, you just have dry skin, or red skin, that it's way more serious than that.
我们应该对那些试图想象这种情况的人说明一下，我们不是说你只是有干性皮肤或红皮肤，这要严重得多。
Yeah, there's an arthritis that is associated with psoriasis, which I actually have. And it makes your joints and everything terribly painful. They swell up. I've had times when I couldn't walk. And that's scary. So I thought I would, you know, why not see if Joao could heal me, too.
是的，银屑病还伴有关节炎，我确实患有这种病。它让你的关节和其他部位疼痛难忍。它们会肿胀。我有过连路都走不了的时候。那很可怕。所以我想，为什么不试试若昂能不能也治好我呢。
Good morning. On behalf of [? Medio ?] Joao Teixeira de Faria, welcome you all to his spiritual center. All belief systems are welcome here.
早上好。我谨代表若昂·特谢拉·德·法里亚，欢迎各位来到他的心灵中心。这里欢迎所有信仰体系。
So where are we now?
所以我们现在在哪儿？
We're in line at the Casa. The Casa is the place where Joao does his healing. It's like a little healing center, compound. And this is the first time we're going to meet him, and then see if he can cure us. It's just early in the morning. We're in the middle of a crowd of, like, 300 or 400 people. And most of them are Brazilian, but about a quarter of us are foreigners from the US and, really, all over the world. Everyone's dressed in white, head to toe. It's like the Casa dress code. You've got to dress in white. And it's funny, they've got Enya bumping over the PA system.
我们在“Casa”排队。“Casa”就是若昂进行治疗的地方。它就像一个小型的治疗中心、复合建筑。这是我们第一次见到他，看看他能不能治愈我们。现在还是清晨。我们处在三四百人的人群中间。他们大多数是巴西人，但大约四分之一是我们这些来自美国以及世界各地的外国人。大家从头到脚都穿着白色的衣服。这是Casa的着装要求。你必须穿白色。很有意思，他们通过公共广播系统播放恩雅的音乐。
Basically, you have all these people just waiting out in this grand hall, waiting to go before Joao. It just feels like a gigantic low-cost medical clinic.
基本上，所有这些人都在这个大厅里等着，等着去见若昂。感觉就像一个巨大的低成本医疗诊所。
Everybody in this first line, please step back a little bit so that we can form the line. It's about 10 deep right now.
第一排的每个人，请稍微往后退一点，这样我们才能排好队。现在大概有10个人深。
There's just sick people everywhere.
到处都是生病的人。
So Davy, so I know that your mom hired a translator and a guide for you guys. Is she there with you during this part?
戴维，我知道你妈妈为你们雇了一位翻译和导游。她在这一部分和你们在一起吗？
Yeah, she's right there. Her name is Heather. While we were waiting there, she told us how Joao had come to be Joao. It wasn't going through medical school.
在，她就在那儿。她叫希瑟。我们等待的时候，她告诉我们若昂是如何成为若昂的。他没有上过医学院。
He has a second grade education. And when he was 16 years old, he was coming out of a town called Campo Grande in Mato Grosso. And he'd just lost his job as a tailor's assistant. And he was hungry and tired and lonely and on his way home.
他只有小学二年级的学历。当他16岁时，他正从马托格罗索州一个叫大坎普的镇子出来。他刚刚失去了裁缝助手的工作。他又饿又累，孤独一人，正在回家的路上。
And basically, while he was there on the road, what happened to Joao was he was visited by the spirit of St. Rita. And she gave him just, like, this unfamiliar address. She told him, go back into town, knock on the door at this house.
基本上，当他在路上时，发生在若昂身上的事情是，他被圣丽塔的灵魂拜访了。她给了他一个陌生的地址。她告诉他，回到镇上，敲开那户人家的门。
They said, "Are you Joao?" He said, "I'm Joao, I was told to come here. They said, "We've been waiting for you."
他们问：“你是若昂吗？”他说：“我是若昂，有人让我来这里。”他们说：“我们一直在等你。”
The next thing he remembered is coming out of a faint. And he was very apologetic and said, "Gosh, I must have been so hungry that I fainted. I'm so sorry." And they said, "Oh, no. You incorporated King Solomon and you've just healed over 50 people.
他记得的下一件事是从昏迷中醒来。他非常抱歉地说：“天哪，我一定是因为太饿而晕倒了。我很抱歉。”他们说：“哦，不。你被所罗门王的灵魂附身了，你刚刚治愈了50多人。”
You've incorporated King Solomon. What does that mean?
你被所罗门王附身了。那是什么意思？
Incorporating, it's like channeling, except instead of just channeling the voice of a spirit, basically your whole body becomes completely possessed. So the idea is that there's 37 of the world's greatest healers of all time, and they just kind of take turns entering his body and performing these works of healing. They call these guys the entities.
附身，就像通灵一样，只是不仅仅是传导一个灵魂的声音，基本上你的整个身体完全被占有了。所以，理念是世界上有37位历史上最伟大的治疗师，他们轮流进入他的身体，并进行这些治愈工作。他们把这些人称为“实体”。
And are these healers that we would have heard of? Are these, like, famous people?
这些是我们听说过的治疗师吗？他们像名人吗？
Oh, there's a few all stars on this roster. You know, there's St. Ignatius and St. Francis, King Solomon. There's a guy named Dr. Octavio Cruz, he's like the father of Brazilian medicine. Each of these spirits has a different personality. In fact, the music that they play over the loudspeakers there, each one has a separate musical preference. So depending on which entity Joao is channeling, they'll play whatever music they most like.
哦，名单上有几位全明星人物。你知道，有圣依纳爵、圣方济各、所罗门王。还有个叫奥塔维奥·克鲁兹医生的人，他就像巴西医学之父。这些灵魂每一个都有不同的个性。事实上，他们通过扬声器播放的音乐，每一个都有各自喜欢的音乐。所以取决于若昂正在传导哪个实体，他们就会播放他们最喜欢的音乐。
OK, so you guys are standing there in this big room with hundreds of people in this line. How long does that last?
好了，你们站在那个大房间里，排着数百人的长队。那持续了多久？
About a couple of hours. And then Heather says it's our turn. She gets me and my mom into the right line and kind of sends us through to see Joao.
大约几个小时。然后希瑟说轮到我们了。她把我推到正确的队列，我们就这样去见若昂。
Just keep coming through. I'll meet you inside.
继续往前走。我在里面接应你们。
First, we go through a couple of rooms where there's just a bunch of people meditating in chairs with their eyes closed. And then, finally, you can see him just way up at the front of the room. He sits in a big, wooden chair. It's almost like a throne. And he's got a beige shirt on, hospital scrubs. He's about 50 years old maybe, dark, wavy hair, round face, glasses. He's sitting there and he's got, like, a ballpoint pen and just a bunch of little slips of paper on his lap. And as each person goes in front of him for a few seconds, he does a real quick little scribble and just gives them the scrap of paper. It's almost like some old baseball player giving autographs at a baseball card show.
首先，我们穿过几个房间，里面有一群人在椅子上闭着眼睛冥想。然后，最后，你可以看到他就在房间的最前面。他坐在一把大木椅上。几乎就像一个王座。他穿着米色的衬衫，手术服。他大约50岁，深色的波浪头发，圆脸，戴着眼镜。他坐在那里，膝盖上放着一支圆珠笔和一叠小纸条。当每个人在他面前停留几秒钟时，他会快速乱画几下，就把那张纸条给他们。简直就像某个棒球老将给棒球卡展上的球迷签名一样。
So when we get up to see him, Heather explains my mom's deafness to him and she tells him about my psoriasis to Joao in Portuguese.
当我们走近见他时，希瑟向他解释了我妈妈的耳聋情况，并用葡萄牙语告诉了若昂我的银屑病。
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
[葡语对话]
To me, this is like the moment of truth maybe. But Joao barely looks at us. I mean, he just kind of nods and gives us one of those papers with this crazy squiggle on it. And Heather tells us it's our prescription. She says that Joao, he doesn't have to actually examine us because the entities have just been checking us out as we were approaching him in line. And she points me and my mom to a room where everyone's meditating and just says, you know, go over there, sit in current. They call it sitting in current.
对我来说，这可能是真相大白的时刻。但若昂几乎没看我们一眼。我的意思是，他只是点点头，给了我们一张纸，上面有那个疯狂的涂鸦。希瑟告诉我们这是我们的药方。她说若昂不需要真的检查我们，因为实体在我们排队靠近他时已经检查过我们了。她指引我和妈妈去一个大家都在冥想的房间，就说，去那儿，坐入“电流”中。他们称之为“坐电流”。
Go sit in the other current room. You stay here till the end. Hold on to that. That's your medicine. I'll tell you later.
去坐进另一个电流房。待在那儿直到最后。拿好那个。那是你的药。我稍后再告诉你。
Current means like the current, the electrical current that comes from all the entities?
“电流”是指所有实体发出的那种电流，电荷吗？
Well, when you sit in current, it's like this, everyone that's there meditating is sort of conducting this powerful, spiritual current. And that gives energy to Joao and the entities while they're doing the healing.
嗯，当你坐入电流中时，就像这样，在场的所有冥想者都在传导这种强大的精神电流。这为若昂和实体进行治疗时提供了能量。
So you sit in this current room and you're just supposed to keep your eyes closed, make sure not to cross your arms or your legs because that disrupts the flow of energy. Most people in there are sitting pretty still. A couple people have fallen asleep. There's people that are making this weird, spooky, hissing sound. It sounds like this.
所以你坐在电流室里，你只需要保持双眼闭合，确保不要交叉双臂或双腿，因为这会阻碍能量的流动。大多数人在里面坐得很静。几个人睡着了。有人发出一种奇怪、阴森的嘶嘶声。听起来像这样。
[HISSING SOUND]
[嘶嘶声]
So after like an hour of that, we all went outside and Heather told us to go the pharmacy window. Behind the counter there, it's just a kid sitting on a little stool, probably, like, 15-year-old kid with a Casa t-shirt.
大约一个小时后，我们都出去了，希瑟叫我们去药房窗口。柜台后面坐着一个孩子，坐在一个小板凳上，大概是个穿着Casa T恤的15岁男孩。
So me and my mom, we give this kid our pieces of paper with like Joao's scribble on it. And he really doesn't even look at the paper. He just takes them from us. He reaches down into this cardboard box at his feet and he pulls out some pill bottles and just gives us the pills. They're like these little Joao brand pills. And then I see him give the same pills to the guy behind me, and the person behind that guy. We all get the same exact pill bottles.
我和妈妈把那张若昂乱涂乱画的纸条递给这个孩子。他真的连看都没看一眼纸条。他就直接从我们手中拿走。他伸手够向脚下的一个纸箱，取出几个药瓶递给我们。它们就像那些“若昂牌”的小药丸。然后我看见他把同样的药瓶给了我后面的人，以及那个人后面的人。我们都得到了完全一样的药瓶。
It's got a [? jaguar ?] on the back.
上面有个美洲豹。
Heather tells us that these pills, they're just a passion flower extract, but the entities spike each capsule with a special energy.
希瑟告诉我们，这些药丸只是西番莲提取物，但实体为每一粒胶囊注入了特殊的能量。
It's a vehicle to carry the energy that is imbued into the herbs for that particular person. Unique for you, so you can't give it your sister, your brother. It is for your condition.
这是一种载体，承载着为特定个人注入草药中的能量。对你是独一无二的，所以你不能把它给你的姐妹或兄弟。它是专门针对你的病症的。
So Heather tells us what Joao's treatment plans are for me and my mom. Me and my mom are scheduled for surgery.
希瑟告诉我们若昂给我和妈妈定的治疗计划。我和妈妈被安排进行手术。
Wait, wait. Surgery? You mean like, surgery surgery? Like, they cut into you?
等等，等等。手术？你是说像，那种外科手术？就像，他们会切开你的身体？
Well, no, it's psychic surgery. You're told this is how it works. Basically, you just sit in this room with 20 other people in a chair and the entities perform surgery on you. You just can't see it happen. I mean, Joao is not even in the room.
嗯，不，是精神外科手术。你被告知手术就是这么进行的。基本上，你只需要和另外20个人坐在一间房的椅子上，实体就会为你进行手术。你只是看不见它发生。我的意思是，若昂甚至都不在房间里。
And you get the surgery, too?
你也做了手术吗？
Yeah, I get surgery, too. I mean, I sit next to my mom and we have the surgery together.
是的，我也做了手术。我的意思是，我和妈妈坐在一起，我们一起做了手术。
I'm sitting here and my mom is next to me and she's breathing. I can feel her breathing really slowly and sort of intensely. And I'm not feeling anything, but I don't know. I'm hoping she's experiencing something. It seems strange now, but I was so kind of disoriented. And just everything was so weird. I never really felt like I had steady footing. I didn't know what was going on. I don't know, I felt like maybe it could all be real.
我坐在那里，妈妈就在我旁边，她在呼吸。我能感觉到她呼吸得非常缓慢且专注。我没感觉到什么，但我不清楚。我希望她能体验到什么。现在回想起来觉得很奇怪，但我当时太困惑了。一切都太诡异了。我从未觉得自己的脚步是稳的。我不知道发生了什么。不知道，我感觉也许这一切可能是真的。
Heather, she warns us. She says, you know, don't be too active right after invisible surgery, because you can rip out the invisible sutures that the entities have just put in. She says, you've got to treat it just like you would conventional surgery. And just stay in bed. And in fact, after these invisible surgeries, we were both totally exhausted. And we went to our rooms and we just slept soundly, totally for about 24 hours.
希瑟警告我们。她说，你知道，隐形手术后不要太活跃，因为你可能会撕裂实体刚刚缝合好的隐形缝线。她说，你必须像对待常规手术一样对待它。待在床上。事实上，在这些隐形手术后，我们两个都精疲力竭了。我们回到了房间，睡得很沉，一共睡了大约24小时。
The next morning, I wake up and I can look down and see there's been no miracle for my skin. I'm not cured. And it was really humid, so my tape recorder was sticking a little bit. So the sound's a little bit funny, but this is tape of me just kind of going down to visit my mom for the first time after the surgery.
第二天早上，我醒来往下看，发现我的皮肤并没有奇迹发生。我没有被治愈。当时湿度很大，所以我录音机的带子有点粘住。所以声音有点奇怪，但这录音是我手术后第一次去看我妈妈。
It's the morning after surgery and I feel pretty groggy. I slept almost 24 hours straight, and I'm ravenous. I'm going to go down to breakfast and see if my mom can hear again.
这是手术后的早晨，我觉得有点昏昏沉沉。我连续睡了快24小时，饿极了。我要去吃早餐，看看我妈能不能听见了。
Going downstairs. I hear some voices down there on breakfast. There she is. She's talking to someone. Well, she's looking at something.
下楼了。我在早餐时听到了一些声音。她在那儿。她在和某人说话。嗯，她在看某样东西。
Hey Mom. Mom. I'm right behind you. She doesn't see me.
嘿，妈妈。妈妈。我就在你后面。她没看见我。
Hey Mom. Mom. I'm right in your ear. Mom, can you hear me? Can you hear me? She can't hear me.
嘿，妈妈。妈妈。我就在你耳边。妈妈，你能听见吗？你能听见吗？她听不见我。
OK, so clearly at this point, you probably realize like, OK, your mom didn't get her hearing back. Did they warn you that it wasn't going to be like, OK, man puts his hands on you and, kaboom, you know, that suddenly you get your hearing back? But that it might take weeks or more?
好了，显然到了这一点，你可能意识到，好吧，你妈妈没有恢复听力。他们有没有警告过你，这不是那种“某人手放在你身上，砰的一声，你突然就能听见了”的那种？而是可能需要几周甚至更久？
Yeah. They said there's a whole range of possibilities. Some people are healed instantly. Some people, it takes a couple of weeks. Some people, a couple months. Some people, a couple years. But still, change will happen a little bit at a time. So I tapped her on the shoulder and I asked her if she felt any different? And she said she thought she felt like a greater sensitivity to vibration. Maybe it could be a sign that her hearing was coming back. And then she asked me how I was feeling.
是的。他们说可能性有很多种。有些人立即痊愈。有些人需要几周。有些人几个月。有些人几年。但无论如何，变化会一点一点发生。所以我拍了拍她的肩膀，问她感觉有什么不同吗？她说她觉得对振动的敏感度提高了。也许这可能是她听力正在恢复的迹象。然后她问我感觉怎么样。
How are you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
I don't feel so great. It's either the invisible surgeries and the sutures within me, or it's the runs.
我感觉不太好。要么是因为隐形手术和体内的缝线，要么是因为腹泻。
The rest?
剩下的？
The runs. The R-U-N-S.
腹泻。R-U-N-S。
T-R-U-N-S. What is T-R-U-N-S?
T-R-U-N-S。T-R-U-N-S是什么？
The runs.
腹泻。
The rust?
铁锈？
She's still clearly very deaf.
她显然还是非常耳聋。
Ladies and gentlemen, it's the comedy musings of Ken.
女士们先生们，这是肯的喜剧随笔。
I don't tell jokes. I only channel jokes from the entities.
我不讲笑话。我只传导来自实体的笑话。
This is a few days after our surgeries, and there's sort of a town talent show. I'm translating all of this into sign language for my mom. Most of us foreigners are here for several weeks, so the town's got this whole kind of summer camp feeling.
这是我们手术后几天了，镇上举行了一个才艺秀。我把这一切都翻译成手语给我妈看。我们大多数外国人都在这里待上几周，所以镇上有一种夏令营的感觉。
This is Ken and his doctors at home had given him a few weeks to live. He's got some kind of severe liver problem and he's supposed to die soon.
这是肯，他家乡的医生让他只剩几周的生命了。他患有某种严重的肝病，很快就会去世。
How many entities does it take to change a light bulb?
换个灯泡需要几个实体？
How many?
几个？
Zero, we've already seen the light.
零个，我们已经看见光明了。
So you basically do the same thing every day. Take the pills, you either see Joao, or you spend more time in that current room, the meditation room. And people are so nice. A lot of them are really down to earth. They're really cool and just really friendly. And so I am getting along with people and it's sort of powerful just to be around so many people that have cancer, AIDS, people that are really close to dying.
所以基本上你每天做同样的事情。吃药，要么去看若昂，要么在那间电流房、冥想室里待更久。人们都特别好。很多都很脚踏实地。他们真的很酷，而且特别友好。所以我跟大家相处得不错，身处这么多癌症、艾滋病、临近死亡的人身边，这种感觉挺震撼的。
Why didn't the entity cross the road?
为什么实体没过马路？
Why?
为什么？
He was already on the other side.
他已经在对面了。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
The problem is, everyone's telling you these miracle stories all the time, just constant miracle stories, but you don't see any miracles. People in wheelchairs are still in wheelchairs. Blind folks are still blind. They're like urban legends. And it's like they can smell my skepticism. It's like the way animals can smell fear. And to them, everything that happens, everything that goes on there proves that they're right and that these entities exist. You know, like my back was just starting to kill because you're sitting in this current room for just hours and hours on end. They told me that the pain was proof that the entities are working on me. And I was like--
问题是，每个人都在不断地告诉你这些奇迹故事，没完没了的奇迹故事，但你却一个奇迹都没看见。坐轮椅的人依然坐轮椅。盲人依然失明。它们就像都市传说。而且感觉他们能闻到我的怀疑。就像动物能闻到恐惧一样。对他们来说，发生的每一件事，在那里发生的每一件事，都证明了他们是对的，证明了这些实体存在。你知道，比如我的背部开始剧痛，因为你在那电流室里一坐就是好几个小时。他们告诉我疼痛证明了实体正在为我治疗。而我就像……
So in their view, is there like even room for coincidence? Or--?
所以在他们看来，甚至有巧合的余地吗？还是……？
No. No, anything that happens, whatever happens, happens for a reason. And I mean, it would be one thing if they just asked me to believe or just to try to believe, but they all tried to convince me that it's based on science. Here's a couple examples.
没有。不，发生的任何事情，无论发生什么，都是有原因的。我的意思是，如果他们只是让我去相信或只是尝试去相信那还好，但他们都试图说服我这是基于科学。这儿有几个例子。
Our hearts create a field of energy around our bodies. We know this now. We can measure it.
我们的心脏在我们的身体周围产生一个能量场。我们现在知道了。我们可以测量它。
Each of us holds a vibration, and that vibration attracts other like vibrations and affects other vibrations.
我们每个人都带着一种振动，这种振动吸引其他类似的振动并影响其他振动。
We also know that medium Joao has been hooked up to electrodes and that he goes down to 0 resistance. So he becomes like a lightning rod.
我们还知道通灵者若昂曾连接过电极，他的电阻降到了0。所以他变得像一根避雷针。
Because I'm a Capricorn, I have bad knees. And I felt them working on my knees, and I also felt them working on my elbow.
因为我是摩羯座，我的膝盖不好。我感觉到他们在治疗我的膝盖，我也感觉到他们在治疗我的手肘。
Capricorns are known for having bad knees?
摩羯座以膝盖不好闻名？
Yeah.
是的。
For my mom, the longer her hearing is not coming back, the more obsessed she kind of becomes with just following every little rule of the place. Like, Heather told us we have to stock up on holy water, the holy water they have at the Casa gift shop. And it's really just a regular brand of-- it's just bottled water, but it's been blessed by the entities.
对我妈来说，她的听力迟迟没有恢复，她就变得越发沉迷于遵守这个地方的所有小规则。比如，希瑟告诉我们必须囤积圣水，Casa礼品店里的圣水。其实它就是一个普通的品牌——就是瓶装水，但经过了实体的祝福。
And here, me and my mom are at breakfast. And my mom catches me drinking the regular bottled water.
这儿，我和我妈在吃早餐。我妈发现我正在喝普通的瓶装水。
You'll have to brush your teeth. Humor me and drink this.
你得去刷牙。为了顺着我，喝这个吧。
It's the same thing, except this one is cold.
是一样的，只是这一瓶是凉的。
This has extra energy in it.
这个里面有额外的能量。
What extra energy?
什么额外的能量？
I see the skeptical side of you coming to [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and I think that, for your skin condition, I think it would be healing for you.
我看见你怀疑的一面露出来了，我觉得对于你的皮肤状况，喝这个会有疗效。
I'm having trouble a little bit with the whole program here. Why is this holy water different--?
对于这里整套程序我有点问题。为什么这圣水不一样……？
The entities have really given their energy into this water. They've raised the frequency vibration. And it's a different vibration of [? frequence. ?] It's a charged water, let's call it.
实体确实把他们的能量注入了这水里。他们提高了频率振动。这是一种不同的振动频率。这是一种充能水，我们称之为。
If I gave you the Pepsi challenge, and put some holy water in one cup and some regular bottled water in the other cup, would you tell the difference?
如果我给你做个百事可乐挑战，一个杯子里放圣水，另一个杯子里放普通瓶装水，你能喝出区别吗？
I don't know. Over a period of days of drinking one or the other, I would feel the difference. But talking about the whole program here, Davy, this is-- I know you respect me.
我不知道。经过几天只喝其中一种，我能感觉到区别。但说到这儿的整套方案，戴维，这是……我知道你尊重我。
I do.
我尊重。
This is consistent with everything that I know and have learned in the past 15 years.
这和我过去15年来所知道和学到的一切是一致的。
This is the problem. My mom's trying to use my belief in channeling to get me to belief in Joao.
这就是问题所在。我妈试图用我对通灵的信仰来让我去相信若昂。
Yeah, just to remind people of how you've talked about this in the past, your mom channels this ancient being, Aaron. And the last time you came on the show and talked about it, you described it this way. You said that, basically you faced this choice as her kid. You could decide that channeling isn't real and your mom's a little crazy. And you don't think she's crazy. She's really wonderful in so many ways. And so you sort of provisionally were thinking, OK, well, maybe this is real.
是的，提醒一下人们你过去是怎么谈论这件事的，你妈妈传导那个古老的存在亚伦。你上次来节目谈到它时，你是这样描述的。你说基本上作为一个孩子，你面临这种选择。你可以决定通灵不是真的，你妈有点疯。但你不觉得她疯。她在很多方面都很棒。所以你某种程度上暂时性地在想，好吧，也许这是真的。
Yeah. And I've seen the work that she does with Aaron. And I've seen how helpful it is to people.
是的。我见过她和亚伦所做的工作。我见过这对人们有多大帮助。
Aaron gives people advice?
亚伦会给人们建议？
Yeah, so I've seen the good that comes out of that. But now she's upping the stakes. She's saying, if I'm going to keep believing in Aaron and that stuff, I also have to believe in Joao and the entities.
是的，我见过由此带来的善事。但现在她提高了赌注。她说，如果我要继续相信亚伦和那些东西，我也必须相信若昂和那些实体。
So it's like you're at a kind of showdown with her?
所以就像你和她处于某种摊牌状态？
Yeah. And I didn't realize this was going to happen. But it's true, at home it's easy to sort of each believe what we want to believe and just, it never has to come to a head.
是的。我没想到会这样。但确实，在家里我们各自相信想相信的东西很容易，它从来不需要达到顶峰。
So is there any point down there when you thought that you started to believe a little bit?
那么在那儿有没有一点你觉得你开始相信了？
Yeah, actually. There was one day.
有，事实上。有一天。
All those who have surgery, please raise there hand.
所有接受手术的人，请举手。
So what's going on now?
那么现在发生什么了？
We're at the Casa. We're going to see some physical surgeries.
我们在Casa。我们要去看一些物理手术。
Oh, you mean like real surgeries?
噢，你是说像真的手术？
Yeah, knife.
是的，动刀的。
He does those, too?
他也做那些？
Yeah. He cuts into people. Scrapes their eyes. No anesthetic. Joao wouldn't let me record the operations, but he let me stand right there next to him while he did them.
是的。他切开人们。刮他们的眼睛。没有麻醉。若昂不让我录制手术过程，但他让我站在他旁边看他做。
I knew this morning that a couple of the people I'd gotten to be friends with, Gregor and Cynthia, they're from Baltimore. Gregor has MS, so he's in a wheelchair. And Cynthia has some ailments, so she wanted to get surgery, too.
我知道今天早上我结识的几位朋友，格雷戈和辛西娅，他们来自巴尔的摩。格雷戈患有多发性硬化症，所以他坐轮椅。而辛西娅有一些疾病，所以她也想做手术。
OK, so how's it go? You go in there with Cynthia and she's in there with him. What's he do?
好了，过程是怎样的？你和辛西娅一起进去，她和他在一起。他做了什么？
Well, she's standing there with her eyes closed and he just kind of tilts her head back a little bit. He's got this wicked-looking instrument. They call it a Kelly clamp. It's about seven inches long. It's basically a long, metal skinny scissors with a little cotton ball kind of in the pliers tip of it.
嗯，她闭着眼睛站在那儿，他把她的头稍微往后仰一点。他拿着这个看起来很恐怖的器械。他们称之为凯利钳。大约七英寸长。基本上就是长金属细剪刀，尖端有个棉球。
OK, I can feel where this is going. Let me just warn people, this might get a little graphic. OK, continue Davy.
好了，我能感觉到接下来要发生什么了。让我警告一下大家，这可能会有点重口味。好的，继续戴维。
He tilts her head back. He dips the point of it just kind of up her right nostril. And then he turns around and just slams it all the way in, so just all the way to the handle, straight back into her head.
他把她的头往后仰。他把尖端探进她的右鼻孔。然后他转身，直接把它一直塞了进去，直到握柄处，直接扎进她的头里。
Oh my God.
我的天。
It was horrifying. It was the most upsetting thing I've ever seen. The room kind of started swirling around me. And everything got really silent. There's sort of like a roar fills your ears. And I just kept watching as he started kind of poking and jabbing around in there. It was like if you're trying to scrape in a jar of peanut butter to get the last little bit out.
太恐怖了。这是我见过的最令人不安的事情。房间开始在我周围旋转。一切都变得非常寂静。好像有一阵轰鸣声充斥着你的耳朵。我只是盯着看他开始在里面戳弄。就像你在试图刮花生酱瓶子里的最后一点一样。
OK, and so what is she doing? Is she like screaming? Like, what's she doing?
好了，那她当时在做什么？她是在尖叫吗？她表现如何？
She's just standing there, pretty calmly. I mean, she looks maybe a little uncomfortable. But she's very calm.
她就站在那儿，很平静。我的意思是，她看起来可能有点不舒服。但她非常平静。
Then what happens?
然后发生了什么？
Well, then after 30 seconds of that, he pulls the thing out and she kind of just collapses into a chair. And they wheel her off into this sort of infirmary. And that's the last I see of her for a little while. So I go and just sit down in one of these chairs for another hour or two. I'm freaking out. Because like, I just saw something that should not be possible, that there's no way that could happen. What he just did should have killed her and it didn't. I have to say, it was an hour or two like I've never had before. And I was just completely shaken. I was just sitting there and I didn't know what to believe.
嗯，30秒后，他把东西拔出来，她就瘫倒在椅子上。他们把她推到了一个类似医务室的地方。那是之后我见到她的最后一面。所以我去坐了一两个小时。我吓坏了。因为我刚刚看到了一些不该可能发生的事，没有任何方法能让它发生。他刚才所做的本该杀了她，但她却没事。我不得不说，那是我经历过的从未有过的几个小时。我整个人都震撼了。我坐在那儿，不知道该相信什么。
After I'd been sitting there for a couple hours, I went outside and I was standing with Gregor, her husband, who's in a wheelchair. And he was anxious about how she was and then she comes kind of skipping out, just happy as can be. Of course, she'd had her eyes closed the whole time.
坐了几个小时后，我到外面和格雷戈站在一起，她丈夫，他坐在轮椅上。他很担心她的情况，然后她兴高采烈地蹦了出来，开心极了。当然，她全程都闭着眼睛。
What does the thing actually even look like, the apparatus? Is it big or is it small? I have no idea.
那东西实际上长什么样，那个装置？它是大还是小？我毫无头绪。
It's about a seven-inch scissors, like--
大约七英寸的剪刀，像……
Scissors? Now I'm getting scared.
剪刀？我现在开始害怕了。
I don't know if it's a good thing for me to describe it to you. Honestly, he twisted it back, so it was going like almost straight back into your brain. And then he just jammed it all the way in. I mean, I thought he had killed you. I honestly did.
我不知道描述它对我来说是不是好事。老实说，他把它扭转过来，所以它是几乎笔直地插进你的大脑。然后他只是把它一直塞进去。我的意思是，我以为他杀了你。我真的是这么想的。
And so did you go and tell your mom? Like, what did your mom make of it?
那你有没有去告诉你妈？你妈对这件事怎么看？
She had an explanation for exactly what was happening.
对于到底发生了什么，她有一个解释。
The frequency of vibration of these tools is raised so high that they simply become energy and light. Material is transmuted literally into light. And then, as the instrument withdraws the tool, he releases that energy thrust into it and it turns back into the metal that it was.
这些工具的振动频率被提高得如此之高，以至于它们简单地变成了能量和光。物质实际上被转换成了光。然后，当器械撤回工具时，他将那种能量释放进去，它又变回了原来那种金属。
Then I had talked to a couple doctors and it turns out there's a cavity behind the nose and it goes back a long way.
后来我问过几个医生，结果发现鼻子后面有个空腔，而且它向后延伸很长。
Oh, so there's room for the instrument?
噢，所以是有放器械的空间？
Right. And your brain's surround by bone, so there's no way you can harm it or help it, for that matter, by sticking something up your nose. So really, what Joao did, in the end, isn't proof of miracles, but proof of sinus cavities.
没错。而且你的大脑被骨头包围，所以往鼻子里塞东西既伤害不了它，也帮不了它。所以事实上，若昂最后所做的并不是奇迹的证明，而是鼻窦空腔的证明。
Some day I'm not good, some day I'm very good. It's with ups and downs. That's it.
有时候我不舒服，有时候我状态非常好。有起有伏。就是这样。
There's this couple, Tatiana and Ed. They were from Holland. And you saw them all the time pushing their son around the Casa in a wheelchair, Alexander. He had muscular dystrophy. And the doctors in Holland had said there was no cure, like nothing that could be done for him. Here's Tatiana.
有对夫妇，塔蒂亚娜和埃德。他们来自荷兰。你总是能看到他们推着儿子亚历山大在Casa转悠。他患有肌营养不良症。荷兰的医生说没有治愈方法，什么也做不了。这是塔蒂亚娜。
You know what? The worst in this illness is that you feel helpless. You feel so very helpless. You know that this boy will die little by little every day in front of your eyes, and you can't do anything. It makes you furious. From time to time, you're furious. You're saying, why? Well, I want to do something about that. I can't just watch it happening like that. This is the only, our chance, and the last one.
你知道吗，这种病最糟糕的是你感到无助。你感到非常无助。你知道这个男孩每天都会在你眼前一点点死去，而你却无能为力。这让你愤怒。时不时地，你会愤怒。你会说，为什么？我想对此做点什么。我不能就这样看着它发生。这是唯一的，我们的机会，最后一次机会。
Tatiana hadn't believed in any of this stuff before Alexander got sick. But her and Ed were willing to try anything. The doctors had told them that the muscles would just deteriorate until, at age 18 or so, your heart just can no longer even beat, and he'd die. This is Alexander. He's 10.
亚历山大生病前，塔蒂亚娜从不相信这些东西。但她和埃德愿意尝试任何事。医生告诉他们肌肉会一直退化，直到18岁左右，心脏甚至无法再跳动，他就会死去。这是亚历山大。他10岁。
Well, the entities, they told us positive concentration. So we're working on that. We're doing our best.
嗯，实体告诉我们积极的专注。所以我们正在努力。我们正在尽我们最大的努力。
What's that?
那是什么？
We're doing our best.
我们正在尽力。
Have they told you that you will be healed?
他们告诉过你会痊愈吗？
Yes, they said a couple of times, he will walk. And then he said another time, you will walk very soon. What soon is for the entities, we don't know.
是的，他们说过几次，他会走路。然后另一次说，你很快就会走路。对实体来说“很快”是什么意思，我们不知道。
To me, when I meet people like this, hoping for a miracle, it's really the only choice you have. It seems completely sane to me. It's the logical choice.
对我来说，当我见到这些期待奇迹的人时，这真的是你唯一的选择。这对我来说完全是理性的。这是合乎逻辑的选择。
One night, one of the posadas hired an accordion player and had a little dance. And everyone was there. Maggie, she's blind, and she's dancing with Dennis. Gregor, who uses a walker at home, but he gets up and twirls for a second with Cynthia. Then he topples over again. I mean, everyone who's here, they are so joyful just being together and having hope. And whether or not you believe in the spirits and everything, it just seems like it's good for you. It improves your health to be in a beautiful place.
一天晚上，其中一个客栈雇了一个手风琴手，办了个小舞会。大家都在那儿。玛姬，她是盲人，在和丹尼斯跳舞。格雷戈，他在家使用助行器，但他站起来和辛西娅转了一圈。然后他又倒下了。我的意思是，每一个来这里的人，他们聚在一起抱有希望都感到如此快乐。无论你是否相信灵魂和一切，这看起来对你是有好处的。身处美丽的地方能改善你的健康。
There was 25 people in my mom's group. No one was cured, but everyone was glad that they'd been there.
我妈的那组人里有25个。没有人被治愈，但每个人都为来过这里感到高兴。
Everybody, that is, but you?
除了你？
Right. It wasn't quite enough for me. I mean, my mom still's deaf, my skin's still messed up, and Joao told both of us we needed to come back for more visits. And the worst thing was, my mom and I, we were not seeing eye to eye.
没错。对我来说还不够。我的意思是，我妈还是耳聋，我的皮肤还是很糟糕，若昂告诉我们两个都需要回来进行更多访问。最糟糕的是，我和我妈没能达成共识。
The thing is, can you open your heart to the possibility that this is real, and that in three or four years you could be healed if you do what you need to do? Do you know what I mean?
问题是，你能敞开心扉去接受这可能是真的，并且如果你做你需要做的事情，三四年后你可能被治愈吗？你知道我的意思吗？
Kind of, but I just think you and I see the world differently.
某种程度上，但我只是觉得你我眼中的世界不同。
We probably do. We're two different people. I used to see the world the way you do and I've learned some things by banging my head against the wall and then stopping because I realized it wasn't getting me anywhere.
我们可能确实不同。我们是两个不同的人。我曾经像你那样看待世界，我通过以卵击石学到了一些东西，然后停下来，因为我意识到这对我毫无帮助。
I'm not banging my head. I don't think there is a master plan. I don't think there is a reason for everything. I think there are accidents and coincidences.
我没有以卵击石。我不认为有什么宏大的蓝图。我不认为万事皆有因。我认为有偶然和巧合。
I don't. And I'm not going to argue that one with you. I don't know, Davy. I would hope that you can just say, let's see what happens.
我不这么想。我不会和你争论这个。我不知道，戴维。我希望你只能说，让我们看看会发生什么。
I don't want to let you down, but I don't think I'm going to come back here unless it's to visit you because you've moved here or something.
我不想让你失望，但除非是为了看你，因为你搬到这里了之类的，否则我不觉得我会回来。
You don't think you would come back even though he says he can cure you? That's up to you. That's entirely up to you. That's hard for me to understand why.
你不觉得你会回来，即使他说能治好你？那是你的选择。这完全取决于你。很难理解为什么。
I don't really believe in it.
我并不真正相信它。
That was the first time I had ever told her that, and maybe realized it myself. I don't know what that means exactly for me and my mom.
这是我第一次告诉她，也许我自己也才意识到。我不知道这对我和我妈意味着什么。
You mean, for the two of you who are so close to say, we disagree on something that's so fundamental and such a big part of her life?
你是说，对于两个如此亲近的人来说，在某些如此根本、且在她生活中占如此大一部分的事情上产生了分歧？
Right, because it is everything to her. It's been a couple months since we got back, and she says that she's experiencing some changes. And other people from the group, Maggie, who was blind is saying she's beginning to see a little bit. For my mom, it's the same thing. She says she can feel her inner ears. She can feel changes, shifts, vibrations, and she thinks it's the beginning of hearing.
没错，因为它对她来说就是一切。我们回来几个月了，她说她正在经历一些变化。小组里的其他人，盲人玛姬说她开始能看到一点了。对我妈来说，也是一样。她说她能感觉到内耳。她能感觉到变化、移动、振动，她认为这是听力恢复的开始。
I can feel my voice going up and down. Suddenly, I have some sense of where the notes are. It's completely different.
我能感觉到我的声音在上下波动。突然，我对音符在哪里有了一些感觉。这完全不同了。
Do you hear the difference?
你能听出区别吗？
It's like hearing. It's just vibration. I'm hearing it. I've got to get the tunes, the notes. [SINGING] Amazing grace, how sweet the sound, that saved a soul like me. [END SINGING]
就像听见一样。只是振动。我听到了。我得抓准旋律、音符。[歌唱] 奇异恩典，何等甘甜，我罪已得赦免。[歌唱结束]
Am I way off? Am I better than I was before?
我跑调了吗？我比以前好了吗？
It sounded beautiful to me.
在我听来很美。
Davy Rothbart is about to head out on a 126-city tour for his new book of excerpts from Found magazine, the magazine he created. Details are at foundmagazine.com.
戴维·罗斯巴特即将为他新书《Found》杂志的节选进行126个城市的巡回演讲，那是他创办的杂志。详情请见foundmagazine.com。
[MUSIC -  "AMAZING GRACE" BY DESTINY'S CHILD FEATURING MISSY ELLIOT]
[音乐 - 真命天女组合和米西·埃利奥特演唱的《奇异恩典》]
Coming up, summoning the mysterious entities known as the Food and Drug Administration. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，我们将传召那些被称为“食品药品监督管理局”的神秘实体。一会儿回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Miracle Cures. Stories of kids doing whatever they think it might take, doing the impossible to help their parents get cured. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two is this.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们当然都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“奇迹治愈”。关于孩子们为了帮助父母治愈而做他们认为可能需要的一切、做不可能的事情的故事。我们进入节目的第二幕。第二幕是这样的。
Julia Whitty's dad had cancer, and he had used up all the available kinds of treatment. He probably just had a few months left to live. But there was one hope for him, one last drug that might work. And the problem was, a year of this drug would cost him $47,000, which his insurance couldn't cover and which he could not afford.
朱莉娅·威蒂的爸爸得了癌症，他已经用尽了所有可用的治疗方法。他可能只剩下几个月的时间了。但他还有一个希望，一种可能有效的药。问题是，这种药一年要花47,000美元，他的保险无法覆盖，他也付不起。
So Julia Whitty, she just wrote a magazine article about this experience. She said that she found when she tried to find this drug for him, she found that most of the ways she could get the drug for less were not exactly legal.
所以朱莉娅·威蒂写了一篇杂志文章来记录这次经历。她说，当她试图为他寻找这种药时，她发现大多数能以更低价格买到药的方法都不怎么合法。
I absolutely was willing to break the law and I can't imagine too many people who wouldn't be, in all honesty. If you clearly saw there was a source for what you needed, and if you had to break the law a little bit to cross over the line to go there and get it, I think most people would do that for somebody that they loved. So that was where I began to look around and see if there was some other way we could get this drug.
我绝对愿意触犯法律，老实说，我无法想象有太多人会不愿意。如果你清楚地看到有你所需要的东西的来源，而且如果你必须为了越过界线去买到它而触犯一点法律，我想大多数人都会为他们所爱的人做这件事。所以这就是我开始四处寻找是否还有其他方法可以买到这种药的初衷。
So you started looking around, what'd you find?
所以你开始四处寻找，你发现了什么？
I went on the internet, as most people would in this day and age, I just started surfing around. And I did find-- that's where I first came in contact with people who might have had a loved one who died and had leftover prescription that they would sometimes give away or sell. But obviously, we needed a steady, reliable, long-term dose of this stuff. And I eventually was able to locate a country that manufactured this drug for completely different diseases. And they were selling it for about $1,200 a year, which obviously started to sound really cheap.
我在互联网上找的，就像在这个时代大多数人会做的那样，我只是开始到处搜索。我确实发现了——那是我第一次接触到可能家里有爱人去世并留有处方药的人，他们有时会赠送或出售。但显然，我们需要稳定、可靠、长期的药物供应。最终，我设法找到了一个制造这种药的国家，但它是用于完全不同的疾病。他们卖的价格大约是一年1,200美元，这显然听起来非常便宜。
As compared with $47,000 per year?
相比一年47,000美元？
Exactly.
正是。
So you go, you fly to some foreign country, you get some doctor there, I guess, to prescribe the drug?
所以你飞往某个外国，找那里的医生开处方吗？
Right, which is not difficult to do in other countries. It's pretty much not difficult to do in any country if you're a traveler.
是的，在其他国家这并不难做到。如果你是个旅行者，在任何国家几乎都不难做到。
Did you have to actually claim that you had a disease or did you just tell the doctor, here's my situation.
你是必须声称自己得了病，还是直接告诉医生你的处境？
I told him the truth regarding my father. And he was more than willing. I think he felt good being able to help me.
我告诉了他关于我父亲的真相。他非常乐意。我想他能帮到我感觉很好。
And at this point, you're not exactly sure if it's legal to bring these back?
在这一点上，你不完全确定带它们回来是否合法？
That's right.
没错。
So what do you do?
那你做了什么？
Well, I had thought about it in advance, because I travel in my adult life and I've spent a lot of time in third world countries and stuff. And I usually travel with a pretty hefty medical arsenal. You know, I'd put multiple pills in one bottle. So I thought, well, I'm just going to go there. However they come, I'm going to take them out of that packaging and put them in empty prescription bottles that I have with other prescription names on them. And in all my years of traveling, I've never come back into the US and had anybody open my bottles. So I really didn't think I was going to have trouble with this.
嗯，我提前考虑过了，因为我在成年生活中经常旅行，在第三世界国家待过很长时间之类的。我旅行时通常会带一个相当庞大的医疗储备。你知道，我会把多片药丸放在一个瓶子里。所以我想，嗯，我要去那儿。无论它们怎么包装，我都会把它们拿出来，放进我有的其他处方药名称的空药瓶里。在我多年的旅行中，我回美国时从来没人打开过我的药瓶。所以我真的没觉得会有麻烦。
And so this is like, dozens of pills or hundreds of pills?
所以这就像是，几十片药丸还是几百片？
It was somewhere between two-, three-, or four-month supply, enough to sort of start my father on it, do a set of scans and see whether or not it was working.
大概是两三个月或四个月的供应量，足以让我父亲开始服用，做一套扫描看看它是否有效。
So you have hundreds of pills, what was the moment like when you finally were coming back into the country?
所以你有几百片药丸，你最终回到国内的时候那一刻是什么样的？
Well, you definitely get that sweaty palms thing going. You wonder, what are they looking for? What expression on your face? You know you're doing something that could be wrong.
嗯，你绝对会手心出汗。你想，他们在找什么？你的脸上是什么表情？你知道你在做一些可能是错的事。
And what do we know about how many people are actually going overseas and bringing back drugs?
对于有多少人真的去海外买药带回来，我们知道多少？
I know that their estimates right now are that between one and two million Americans are getting drugs one way or another from Canada alone.
我知道目前的估计是，仅从加拿大，就有一到两百万美国人通过各种方式获取药物。
And is that legal or is that illegal?
那这到底是合法还是非法的？
In my personal experience, it was probably always illegal, but it wasn't enforced. For whatever reason, it began to be enforced around December of 2002. And I was told by the FDA that they were cracking down at that point.
以我个人的经历，这大概一直是非法的，只是没有强制执行。不管什么原因，大约在2002年12月开始执行了。食品药品管理局告诉我，那时他们正在严厉打击。
Do you know what the penalty would have been if you'd been caught?
你知道如果你被抓到，惩罚会是什么吗？
I don't know, but I remember being so angry at the time that I was perfectly prepared to go to jail. Not that I want to go to jail, but I was just feeling this was an absurd way to have to live. And it was ridiculous, in light of the fact that this drug could be had more inexpensively and why my father couldn't have access to it. I considered it immoral.
我不知道，但我记得当时非常生气，我已经做好了坐牢的准备。并不是我想坐牢，但我只是觉得这是一种荒谬的生存方式。考虑到这种药本可以更便宜地获得，以及为什么我父亲无法获得它，这太可笑了。我认为这是不道德的。
Now, at some point you learned that you might be able to simply order the drug from, what was it, an online manufacturer? Like an online pharmacy?
那么，你在某个时候得知可以直接从，是什么来着，在线制造商订购这种药？就像在线药店？
Not an online pharmacy. That would have been easy. It was the actual manufacturer in this country overseas. And they claimed they were already doing it for other patients in the United States. And they told me it would just sail through US customs and that did not turn out to be the case. It gets held up in US customs in Cincinnati and I began a long series of conversations with FDA officials, sort of case officers. And they tell me, it's illegal. You can't bring this in.
不是在线药店。那倒容易。是海外那个国家的实际制造商。他们声称他们已经在为美国的其他患者这样做了。他们告诉我它会直接通过美国海关，但事实证明并非如此。它在辛辛那提的美国海关被扣留了，我开始了一系列与食品药品管理局官员，类似案件负责人的漫长谈话。他们告诉我，这是违法的。你不能带进来。
And the reason for that law is because they can't vouch for the quality of the drugs? They haven't tested those drugs?
这条法律的原因是因为他们不能保证药物的质量？他们还没测试过这些药物？
Exactly right. They haven't tested those drugs. That's what they say. We haven't tested those drugs, we don't know if they'll be good for you or not.
完全正确。他们还没测试过这些药物。他们就是这么说的。我们还没测试过那些药，我们不知道它们对你是否有好处。
But in a way, that's a legitimate thing. Like. In a way, you'd want the government to actually do that, to say, we have no idea if this manufacturer's reputable and the drug's OK.
但在某种程度上，这是一件合情合理的事情。比如，你确实希望政府真的做这件事，去说，我们不知道这家制造商是否可靠，药是否没问题。
Well, I would argue that I have the right to take that chance myself. We're just simply not allowed to do this. Now, we can bring in foreign-made food and foreign-made clothes and everything else, but we're not allowed to bring in foreign-made drugs because they are untested supposedly.
嗯，我会说我有权自己去冒这个险。我们只是不被允许这样做。现在，我们可以带进外国制造的食品和衣服以及其他所有东西，但我们不被允许带进外国制造的药物，因为它们被假定为未经测试。
There's a passage in your article where you say, "I can go to Europe and buy their wine for less, go to Asia and buy their clothes for less. American companies can buy their raw materials for less overseas, or they can move their operations abroad in order to hire cheaper labor or management. But on a mind-boggling reversal of the American principle of supply and demand, I cannot purchase cheaper drugs and bring them home."
在你的文章中有一段话你说，“我可以去欧洲买他们更便宜的葡萄酒，去亚洲买他们更便宜的衣服。美国公司可以在海外买到更便宜的原材料，或者他们可以把业务转移到国外以雇佣更廉价的劳动力或管理人员。但在一个令人震惊的美国供需原则的颠倒中，我不能购买更便宜的药物并带回家。”
That's right. And that's the part that, to this day, infuriates me, particularly about the new Medicare drug bill, which has expressly now, completely, clearly forbidden Americans to go overseas and bring back drugs for any reason whatsoever.
没错。这就是至今仍让我愤怒的地方，特别是关于新的医疗保险药物法案，现在明确规定完全禁止美国人以任何理由去海外带回药物。
And so the FDA holds this stuff up. How long do they hold it?
所以食品药品管理局扣留了这些东西。他们扣留了多久？
They held it for a couple of weeks. And for the first time, we'd cut his dose in half to try and eke it out, as the package wasn't delivered. Then we cut his dose in half again. Eventually it became clear to me that they were not going to give it to us for any reason whatsoever. And in fact, they were going to destroy it. And that's when I turned to my elected officials. I thought, well, maybe they can help me on this end. One senator, Barbara Boxer, was phenomenally helpful. Her office went to work on it. They just dug their teeth in and they had that package sprung in about 24 hours.
他们扣留了几周。这是第一次，我们把他的剂量减半以求节省，因为包裹没送到。然后我们再次把剂量减半。最终我很清楚他们无论如何都不会把它给我们。事实上，他们打算销毁它。这时我转向了民选官员。我想，也许他们能帮我解决这个问题。一位参议员，芭芭拉·博克瑟，非常给力。她的办公室为此忙活起来。他们死咬住不放，在24小时内就把那个包裹释放了。
And did you end up having to get the senator's office to intervene for you again?
你最后不得不再次让参议员办公室为你干预吗？
Yes, I did.
是的。
Like, every time it would come to the border, the same place, same people?
就像，每次它到达边境，同一个地方，同样的人？
No, eventually I figured out a method with the FDA guy that they were willing to accept. We had to provide these very elaborate excuses of why my father was using the foreign version versus the American version of this drug. We had to sort of basically manufacture excuses.
不，最终我找到了一个食品药品管理局的人愿意接受的方法。我们必须提供这些非常复杂的借口，说明为什么我父亲使用外国版而不是美国版的药。我们必须基本上捏造借口。
Oh, I see. You had to say that the American version didn't work?
噢，我明白了。你不得不说美国版没用？
Didn't work as well for my father for the following reasons, which we pretty much made up. It was pretty bogus, but they went for it. And they did that a few times. That system worked, and then it stopped working.
对我的父亲来说效果没那么好，原因如下，我们基本上是编造的。虽然很假，但他们接受了。他们做了几次。那套系统有效，然后它失效了。
Why, what happened?
为什么，发生了什么？
At the end of 2002, we were bringing in another shipment and playing the game the way we'd learned to play it. And this time just couldn't get it sprung. And that was when I heard that the law, not that the law had changed, but that enforcement of the law had changed. And they were beginning to really crack down now on letting these drugs in.
2002年底，我们正在运送另一批货，并按照我们学到的规则玩这个游戏。但这回就是无法放行。那时我听说法律——不是法律变了，而是法律的执行变了。他们现在开始真正严厉打击让这些药物进入。
The FDA case officer suggested that I go to the US company that manufactured the drug and apply for patient financial assistance.
食品药品管理局的案件负责人建议我去制造这种药的美国公司申请患者经济援助。
Now, that's a special program which lets you say, we don't have the money to pay the $47,000, so give us a break, basically, on humanitarian grounds?
那是一个特殊的项目，允许你说，我们没钱支付那47,000美元，所以基本上在人道主义基础上给我们减免？
That's right. And apparently, a lot of the pharmaceutical companies have these things, whether people know it or not, for their more expensive drugs. And we had actually applied for this at the very beginning, when my father was first prescribed this drug, and he didn't pass. He wasn't poor enough, they thought, so I decided we'd just lie. And I called the patient financial assistance line. They had an 800 number. And I was trying to sort of suss them out on, like, how poor did you really have to be before they would accept you? And she said, well, I can't tell you that. But she did, I think inadvertently, admit the only thing I really needed to know, which was that they don't actually check anything you say on the application.
没错。显然，许多制药公司都有这些项目，无论人们是否知道，针对更昂贵的药物。而在我父亲最初被开这种药时，我们就申请过，但他没通过。他们认为他不够穷，所以我决定我们撒个谎。我打了患者经济援助电话。他们有个800号码。我试图打听他们到底需要多穷才会接受？她说，嗯，我不能告诉你。但她确实，我认为是不小心，承认了我唯一真正需要知道的事情，那就是他们实际上并不会检查你申请表上说的任何内容。
Oh, she said that to you straight out?
噢，她直接那样告诉你的？
She told me straight out. I felt like it was something, she went, oh God, I shouldn't have said that. And in my brain, a little bell just went off and I went, yes.
她直接告诉我的。我感觉就像，她说了之后意识到，噢，上帝，我不该说那话。在我脑子里，一个小铃铛响了，我说，耶。
Now, a few months after your dad died-- and we should say that he didn't die of the cancer, he ended up dying of heart failure-- Congress passed the Medicare drug bill, which was designed to address exactly this problem. If your dad had survived, what would this bill have done for him, which is supposed to, basically, take these expensive drugs and put them within financial reach of people?
那么，在你爸爸去世后几个月——我们应该说他不是死于癌症，他最终死于心脏衰竭——国会通过了医疗保险药物法案，旨在解决这个问题。如果你爸爸幸存下来，这项法案会为他做什么？它基本上旨在将这些昂贵的药物置于人们的财务承受范围内。
Well, I ran the numbers on it and I found that he would have still had to pay over $6,000 a year. And obviously, that's a lot cheaper. It's still not as cheap as the $1,200-a-year version you could get overseas.
嗯，我计算了数据，发现他仍然需要每年支付超过6,000美元。显然，那便宜多了。它仍然没有你在海外能买到的那种一年1,200美元的便宜。
So is that good or bad, as far as you're concerned, getting it down to $6,000 to--
所以，从你的角度来看，把它降到6,000美元是好事还是坏事——
It's not good enough. It's not good enough, in my opinion, not if the drug companies are going to be able to ask $47,000, in my father's case, for a drug that all the research and development was done more than 40 years ago. If they have the right to do that, then I think we need to have something. If the government's going to become the biggest drug buyer on the planet, then they need to do something about enacting price controls or setting standards that they're willing to pay.
还不够好。在我看来这还不够好，如果制药公司能够要求47,000美元，以我父亲的案例为例，买一种所有研究和开发都在40多年前就完成的药。如果他们有权这样做，那么我认为我们需要做点什么。如果政府要成为地球上最大的购药者，那么他们就需要对实施价格管制或设定他们愿意支付的标准采取行动。
The thing you're talking about is actually that, under the bill, the United States government would not be able to negotiate for lower prices. They wouldn't be able to say, we're buying a huge quantity, so give us a price break?
你谈论的实际上是，根据该法案，美国政府将无法谈判更低的价格。他们无法说，我们正在购买大量药物，所以给我们打折？
Right. Congress expressly forbade that in the Medicare drug bill.
没错。国会在医疗保险药物法案中明确禁止了这一点。
And as you note in your article, when the government buys anything in quantity, they negotiate the price down.
正如你在文章中指出的，当政府大量购买任何东西时，他们会通过谈判压低价格。
That's right. That's another case, I think, where the pharmaceutical industry wrote the law.
没错。我认为这是另一个制药业编写法律的案例。
And do you blame the drug companies for that?
你把这归咎于制药公司吗？
I blame the drug companies at getting through to our elected officials, yes. They're obviously phenomenally powerful, as we can see by the number of lobbyists that they employ: 600, more than one for every member of Congress. There's a personal lobbyist, in effect, for every member of Congress.
我归咎于制药公司能够通达我们的民选官员，是的。正如我们从他们雇佣的说客人数中所看到的那样，他们显然极其强大：600人，平均每个国会议员不止一个说客。实际上，每位国会议员都有一个私人说客。
Julia Whitty's story about getting her dad's $47,000 prescription filled is in the issue of Mother Jones . That is on newsstands now, and it's at motherjones.com.
朱莉娅·威蒂关于她父亲获得47,000美元处方药的故事刊登在《琼斯母亲》杂志上。报刊亭现在有售，也可以在motherjones.com看到。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Wendy Dorr, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, and Jane Golombisky, who is getting married today. Yes, today. We're going to have to call her Jane Feltes from now on. Our warmest wishes to her and to Rick.
嗯，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我制作，还有温迪·多尔、戴安·库克、莎拉·柯尼格和简·戈隆比斯基，她今天结婚。没错，就是今天。我们以后得叫她简·费尔特斯了。我们要向她和里克致以最温暖的祝福。
Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey Dilts.
我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯尔西·迪尔茨协助制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for free. Or, if you care, you can buy CDs of them now. Well, you know, you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times , all at audible.com.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，您可以免费收听我们的节目。或者，如果您愿意，现在可以购买它们的CD。嗯，你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目，畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com上。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. He came into the studio this week to watch us do the radio show. His review?
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。他这周来到演播室看我们做电台节目。他的评价？
It was horrifying. It was the most upsetting thing I've ever seen.
太恐怖了。这是我见过的最令人不安的事情。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多关于美国生活的故事回来。
The room kind of started swirling around me and everything got really silent. You know, there's sort of, like, a roar fills your ears.
房间开始在我周围旋转，一切都变得非常寂静。你知道，有一阵类似轰鸣声充斥着你的耳朵。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。